hi my name is the Volgin and today I'm
gonna talk to you about channel
memberships I know what you're thinking
you already have the pre-eternal correct
but certain people don't like patreon
they do not agree with patreons business
practices or whatever the case may be so
this is my channel memberships are being
used I think I've had this setup since
last July it's just been sitting there
ready to go ready to launch but for
whatever reason maybe the fact that I
have a camera now means I can more
directly talk to people makes it better
I had to make a video had they actually
launched this so apologies if you
thought this was another SCP video it's
not more videos are coming this year I
just decided to take a little bit of a
break at the start of this year because
I was getting really burnt out towards
the end of last year I've been working
on patreon requests on some specialized
projects at the start of this year one
of them being a contest entry on the SCP
wiki link in the description if you
would like to read it I didn't write it
by the way I did an animation or a
pseudo on a mission for
the last part of it anyway I will make
this quick because it's not content
please become a member if you do not
like patreon or YouTube is more
convenient for whatever reason it's all
the standard affair you get the emotes
you get the sub badges with my logo on
it let me know if you dislike the emotes
if you are a member
don't let me know if you're not a member
because that's rude this is completely
optional nothing will change if you're
not a member you will just get extra
things if you are a channel member and
that's everything thanks for listening
if indeed you still are I'll see you all
in the next video well dr. Miller we'll
see you in the next video but goodbye